free overtime game here against the
Lakers right yeah that was this year
right no that was last was that last
year against us oh that was last year
yeah
there's something about this building
about this building oh I think I mean
obviously uh
truth be told there was defense being
played but there was tough shots being
made
um obviously a lot of it has to do with
letting people get in the Rhythm but I
mean we I feel like we made just about
every shot tough for Kauai he missed six
shots out of 22 so like there's not much
you can really do about that so uh I
mean they made 26 threes 26 or 45 almost
shooting 60 from three uh we just had to
grind this game out we we're on the
second night of it back to back but
it is what it is we have a younger team
than them so
um and it led to kind of that infusion
of energy you needed to to make this
happen yeah man this is uh obviously
that's one of the better teams in the
league one of the deepest teams in the
league
um at the end I just wanted to try to
make it tough on PG
um just trying to pick up do whatever we
could do to kind of speed them up
obviously that's a like I said that's a
older team more vets
um
very physical you know they want to slow
the game down and that's all we did we
just tried to speed them up tell me
about the last play
you drive in the hammer action Baseline
yeah actually he lost the ball no I was
looking for it but was that the call
yeah that was that was that was the call
um
Triano drew that up man oh yeah he got a
lot of a lot of quick hitters for threes
uh
he about gave it away but once I saw a
norm once I saw Norm kind of bait to the
corner too too hard
um obviously in basketball it's a very
read and reactive sport so uh he saw
where Norm was he slid to an open spot
and all I had to do was throw it to him
and we know each other gonna be there
most of the time so
um we're gonna be there
that's the second highest scoring game
in NBA history what was it like just to
be a part of it and then to keep coming
up with a big shot after Big Shot for
your team man it was fun uh it was fun
the atmosphere was crazy man I seen all
the kings fans in here too man live it
was loud from the King side too as well
so
um we just we just stick stuck with it
man um got down like 10 or 12 at one
point um and the fourth came back
um we just had our heads up man and then
and we knew they was going to let us
back in it um
big 45
I mean every single point uh I think
from everybody though on this team
counted um I said there wasn't a lot of
stops but I think we got timely stops we
whenever we needed to get a stop I think
we got it um obviously
we don't want to play in a game like
this again
so
yeah so uh I think we have to be more
consistent defensively when we talk
about this we've talked about this all
year
um
I mean that's that is what it is right
there
and this is a very good long defensive
physical team how were you able to get
at The Rim the way you did
um that's a good question
um domas um is is great in your pocket
and um I was hitting them early and um I
knew they was going to start playing me
for the past and um it was just me being
a basketball player making the right
reason just attacking the rim especially
when they go small ball and um Nick at
the five Nico at the five so y'all just
trying to get to the rim as much as
possible
you guys were down 14. 14 that's 12.
we're down six in the first overtime and
six again in the second overtime so like
what's the key in that situation not to
just you know call it a night yeah stick
with it man um the first the first
overtime man I think they hit all four
of their shots open shots and we missed
all three or three or four of ours
um and Toriano told us um they're gonna
it's gonna come back around
um it's gonna flip and it did for us
knowing the historical significance of
this game and the way you guys won is
this the best regular season game you
guys have been a part of how do you rank
the ah
yeah yeah I said it was very high level
offensive play out there today like
for from just about everybody that was
out there
um like I said we we were able to win
this game one I think we I think we
lasted a bit longer uh like I said we're
younger
um and we just try to keep the tempo up
even in the fourth uh even over even in
both overtimes we wanted to keep the
tempo up keep it up
um and I feel like we were able to get
some easy buckets out of that and like I
said
um once we started causing turnovers and
just kind of creating chaos in the game
I think that's kind of where we uh where
we were really successful looked like
you guys were hitting Kauai and taking
it out of his hands a little bit by
using lost his guy and then seemed to
work pretty well
if he was standing at the top then it
was whoever it was yeah whoever was at
the top we were hitting from there
um and like I said after that it's just
a bunch of scramble it's scramble is
communication it's flying around trying
to get deflections
um and that's that's you have to give
someone like Kawhi different looks but
like I said I mean 16 for 22 six for
nine from three
the best you can do is make him make him
get the ball up
it's with the addition of Russell
Westbrook coming in after a back-to-back
had to perform the way you guys perform
what is the statement that you guys have
made tonight as the Sacramento Kings uh
tell us about Westbrook or was the
thoughts about us because I don't give
up I don't I don't give a [__] who's
over there yeah we ain't worried about
that it doesn't matter yeah man we're
here we see you see the league the
talent in this league there are a lot of
talented teams obviously he added talent
to this team
um but we come in we worry about us
we're here too though we coming today
everybody what's up coach said before
the game he said that this game is going
to tell if we are who we say we are
we'll figure out a way to win this game
that's what he said before the game and
you all took it to double overtime and
won the way you did
with the way the West is and the way
that the push is going to be the final
what 23 now is this to you guys a
statement game but is as much also like
a testament to yourselves of like yes
like this is more than possible oh yeah
definitely um
like two weeks before the All-Star break
man
um uh Mike was talking about it um that
we got to close these games out that we
need that we need to win because we got
a tough schedule coming up after this
um man yeah he told us the same thing um
we're gonna see who we are we're gonna
see what we're about tonight too um if
we if we're gonna come out here and play
because they're a physical team um and
they'll be in the playoffs a lot too so
um and we want to get that away at and
we did we have to do
Karen you were talking about this a
little bit earlier I think but there's
going to be some old two watches game
and said 176 to 175 by what happened to
the NBA at 90s nobody's playing defense
anymore what would you say to people who
might have that or something oh well I
mean one there were open shots that were
that that was got there were dunks that
were open
um but you go back and watch
we shot 111 they shot 90 100 shots so a
lot of the 220 shots watch how many were
like tough makes just watch all the
makes like there were a lot of tough
shots that were going in and I think
that's a testament to the talent that's
in the league and then also the pace
that we're playing at
um the way that it's official honestly
there were less free throws than I
thought were taken there's uh 35 and 36
on both ends but I think that there was
a there was a very high level of shot
making
um
I mean 26 threes in a game I'm not sure
what the record is but
yeah is that that's their franchise I
don't know what the NBA record is but I
mean 26 threes like
a lot of them were contested
um yeah it's just that was there was
high level offensive basketball that was
that was being played almost 60 from
that Johnson unless you're just blocked
and a lot of guys in this league unless
you're blocking their shot
especially once they've seen it Go in
two or three times there's not much you
can really do about it so like I said
our our key was to try to turn them over
try to speed them up and we forced 25
turnovers and I think that's where we
won this game two more dear and Mike's
name is coming up more and more in the
coach of the year got to get it you got
to get it he got to get this game
obviously he's going to get a lot of
attention what do you want to say about
just you know his name and his candidacy
for that award I think he'd rather us be
a better defensive team
uh so I think let's let's worry about
that
um I think if if we do step our defense
up
um at the end of the season I think it's
a no-brainer for sure I got to keep
winning games for him my bad bro yeah I
think he should still be it but
um I'm preaching what he preaches so
when you uh took your All-Star break and
you took him inventory of your season up
to that point coming back now what did
you want to be intentional about because
you like in the last couple games coming
off the injury haven't been Mr B yeah uh
I just wanted to get shots up and I'm
not losing my rhythm um I went to Miami
I told you we was talking before I went
to Miami um I got the gym four days uh
out of the five days it was off so
um that worked that worked out for me
shout out to Joel too yeah shout out to
Joel my trainer man get my ankle back
right quick uh so yeah
oh